hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you seeing how your work
week is going I'll tell you right now it
is a rainy gloomy Thursday afternoon out
here in Los Angeles I'll tell you but
yay this is what happens every year
it [ __ ] rains everything turns green
and for like a week it looks like
Portland Oregon out here an absolute
paradise and then it just stops raining
and then the Sun turns all of that
beautiful green [ __ ] brown and then the
Santa Ana winds over they [ __ ] like a
giant nature's hair dryer just heats the
stuff up and then we have our fires and
it's totally 100 percent normal in every
[ __ ] year when this place is burning
down somebody from back east always has
to call me up the October y'all right
what's up with those fires out there
it's what the [ __ ] happens do I call up
people in Buffalo every day though hey
hey all right with that lake effect snow
what's up with that what's up with
Niagara Falls it mean we should put a
fence there somebody's got to go over
every where you live there's something
that makes them you got to pay a price
70 70 degrees and gorgeous every [ __ ]
day you guys have seen me since I've
moved out here you've seen that just
just the JFK level beautiful tan golden
golden brown ginger that I am when I
come to your shows when I was living on
the East Coast I mean I was just like it
was like a [ __ ] Casper the Friendly
Ghost if he actually got in shape the
fat [ __ ] granted my head was the same
size as this you know but ever since I
moved out here man I'm telling you
people have really commented it's like
bill for the first time and you're like
he actually look human
no I'm still pasty as ever blacken as
ugly as ever right that's my biggie
[ __ ] line pasty and as freckled as
ever anyways yes so this is this is one
of these days we just want to say it and
eat some stew you know I love cooking
but I really hate the [ __ ] music on
every how to cook video why does it have
to be just it's so [ __ ] like perky
and everything's gonna be great you know
why I can't get you know any ever work
in a [ __ ] restaurant in the kitchen I
don't mean being the [ __ ]
good-looking [ __ ] douche ooh invites
everybody into the restaurant hi how are
you maybe you'll [ __ ] me if you order
the right [ __ ] food you know not that
person you know I swear to God so much
of beautiful woman's game is giving you
hope how far they can get in the game
how many times they can go around the
board and collect $200 just just on hope
is it's it's [ __ ] incredible
anyways I'm talking about did you ever
work in the [ __ ] kitchen alright
everybody back there you know half the
people there if they don't have a record
they're about ready to get arrested for
something there's always some sort of
drugs going on it's it's just a lot of
degenerates in the cooking industry and
I just don't understand well maybe
that's why they have such Pleasant
[ __ ] music they always have it staged
so it was this giant [ __ ] kitchen and
somebody's just at home and then always
just like I love making toast you know
when I was a little girl just toast to
me was just I mean it just brought the
family together the sound of my mom
pushing the toaster button down the
smell of the bread slowly crunching my
dog muffin at my feet I figured on a
rainy both good Thursday afternoon we
could recreate some of that you know I
just wanted somebody to make a [ __ ]
pork chop on YouTube and talk
how much blow they did in the [ __ ]
80s and now they can't even remember
they can't even believe that they can
remember the difference between pork and
poultry they both begin with P and my
drug dealers last name was Phillips so
it's very confusing time for me but as
far as I remember sorry
anyways I worked last night
I was down at the comedy and magic club
on Hermosa Beach speaking of my lovely
non-existent Tim Donald Trump literally
looks like he has a halo of hair on his
[ __ ] head I just don't understand why
doesn't he just think the hair plugs are
incredible now just take your [ __ ] from
the back and paratroop that [ __ ] I don't
know it's like he has that remember when
Justin Bieber had like that comb-over
haircut which I really found offensive
as a balding man you know that someone
would mock my situation with the full
head of hair and I'll be honest with you
I don't think I ever quite forgave him
for that anyways I'm sorry I'm all over
the [ __ ] map here boy was I just
talking about was talking about people
doing blow in the backs of kitchens
right no it was past that all right you
know what it just it would I was down
Hermosa Beach doing a show with Bobby
Collins Bobby Collins we did a show down
there to raise some money for a great
charity went down there tried out a
bunch of new stuff if you guys are in LA
if you want to go to a great comedy club
I love that [ __ ] place and the people
who run it and the level of like comedy
like memorabilia that they have down
there is is incredible I believe that
guy told me that he has something of
George Carlin's at George war on one of
the specials right like a window or
something like that I'm always afraid to
say it
some [ __ ] lunatic will go down and
try and steal it but it's really
incredible it's like a it's like
performing in the stand-up museum
especially when you saw how old my jokes
were sorry alright let's talk about the
Boston Bruins shall we bill all Billy
freckles
I am back on the [ __ ] bandwagon here
Jesus Christ can somebody close that
door when they [ __ ] flush the toilet
there
I watched the Columbus game which we
lost in overtime I missed last night
which we also lost in overtime but we
still picked up two points all right we
got a lot of people out evidently like
the injury bug has not only hit the
[ __ ] Bruins it's also hit the Celtics
Kyrie Irving is messed up his knee he
was about supposed to be out for a few
games now they're saying it looks even
worse so I don't know what that means
you know the Celtics are not disclosing
how he hurt his knee but I think we all
know okay Kyrie thinks the world is flat
and he was walking like it was flat and
all of a sudden he got to where it
starts to you know go down a little bit
and you know it's like you ever walk
down the stairs and you think you're at
the last one and you're not you know you
missed a stair for something like that
or you think you're at the end and
you're not I think he did that walking
around his house just thinking well the
Earth's flat I don't need to adjust to
the circumference here that's how he
hurt his knee that's a true story
but Ted donato of the Bruins Ted Donato
Ted Donato was like Ryan did not I'm
sorry I'm old son of Ted Donato came up
with the Bruins his first friggin game
he scored a goal and had two assists in
a overtime loss I believe it's five to
four against Columbus was great
what's-his-face Bergeron was saying that
he actually when he was 18
played with Ryan's dad and Ryan was just
a kid and would come to practice and
would skate around as a little kid and
now all of a sudden he's on the team I
think they said Bergeron is 32 years old
Yeah right around that age that's when
that type of [ __ ] starts happening you
know what I mean and it's like you just
remember somebody being like four years
old and next thing you know you wake up
and you're doing like tequila shots with
that little [ __ ] four-year-old being
like how are you of age when did you
turn 21 and the person will be like four
years ago you're like you look 25 yeah I
got a kid you're like what the what the
[ __ ] happened and what happened
was is you stopped growing there's no
more grades
Yatta College once you pass 22 all right
that's this weird [ __ ] face until you
until you get married and have a kid of
your own if you've like me and you just
went all the way into your 40s and never
got [ __ ] married and never had a kid
you live in like this [ __ ] Peter Pan
lifestyle where you like you still
acting like you're 23 and then all of a
sudden someone who was 2 is now 25 and
they're actually married and they have a
kid you know like what what the [ __ ]
what am i doing
and if you like me it just causes you to
drink more I mean why would you sit
there and like you know as an adult and
try to address just exactly what the
[ __ ] are you doing with your life you
know but it's fun it's fun staying out
there for 15 years longer than you
should have just take all the stories
you have maybe that's why that Pleasant
music bothers me maybe those people who
make those those cooking videos maybe
they got married at like 25 when they
were quote supposed to you know so they
didn't you know they didn't stay out
there too long and get all [ __ ] jaded
like uncle freckles here right I'm
supposed to mention this ok second shows
have been added for my my tour my turn
in 50 tour this year in the following
cities a second show has been added my
31st in like a lamb out like a [ __ ]
feature March 31st San Antonio Texas the
stars at night are big and bright Papa
Papa Panov Texas April 6 Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Late Show added do let's go
to parami to get the French fries
matched and then why am i doing a Boston
accent because I'm living
April seventh Cincinnati Ohio Late Show
added baby if you have a wonder wondered
how you're ever gonna get tickets to my
show
hey come on down and see my red nuts
tell show tell jokes sorry
been hacking and stealing [ __ ]
material from openers feature acts and
headliners Nashville Oh
Nashville Tennessee second show added
April 21st let me taste or about a man
named Paul Martin uber kept in bed so
he'd blame black people and screamed at
the Jews I made an evil flag and what
you gonna do Nashville that is the
Predators and hillbillies all right
Minneapolis Minnesota June 29th Late
Show added wait what songs that's it's a
principle we ate it that [ __ ]
something's up to something was it soft
and wet that's my abs after one sit-up
honey
Oh July 14 [ __ ] Portland Oregon man I
added an organic late show for all you
gluten-free [ __ ] hairy cuts up there
July 17th
Seattle Late Show added alright in honor
of the only guy left alive up everyone
cheered oh okay
9:30 September 30th to those of you not
in Europe Denver Colorado
second night second show at it Rocky
Mountain High
Colorado experimental aircraft John
Denver you know if he was wearing his
puffy coat around his head maybe he's
still a third show at it sorry why am i
making fun of John Denver I always liked
that guy
he was always great on the Muppet Show
you know that's not an easy show
everybody says don't perform with kids
or animals what about puppets you know I
was always a tough one you could [ __ ]
you sitting there talking to a goddamn
puppet right the TV screens on you and
the puppet and then you're just you're
sitting there and you're looking down
you can see the puppeteer he's up there
doing the [ __ ] he's down there doing the
voice and the whole time you're trying
to member your lines you like that's
what the guy who does [ __ ] Fozzie
Bear looks like so [ __ ] weird I never
pictured picture I'm looking like that
John lives yo line this is the 12th take
can you get through the [ __ ] take
here anyways I want to thank everybody
who's been coming out all right and
buying tickets to my show I'm turning a
half a century old you understand that
everything on me is 50 years old it's
incredible
my my my this whole [ __ ] mess of a
human being this somehow survived for 50
years hey Bill hey Bill
here's to 50 more here's to 50 more do
you know how to do math sir
I even people do that hey he's do
another 68 do another 60 that would make
them 120 this couple you know the odds
of one of them making it there is
astronomical forget about both of them
days to another 60 when you say that
what you're really doing in a
passive-aggressive way is letting people
know that they're on the they're on the
back nine they're gonna die
hey Bill hits do another 50 I mean I
guess I could make a hundred I mean
what's the world gonna look like at that
point huh a bunch of robots [ __ ]
telling me what to do they could have no
sympathy for me you think people don't
respect human beings in this country
don't respect their elders you wait to
the robots coming around metal [ __ ]
alright I got to do a little
advertisement here have you guys been
watching them
madness all right my bookie all right I
love my bookie you know why cuz they're
not ashamed that they're a bookie unlike
those other people who I don't look at
all those people
Dreamweavers whatever the [ __ ] they call
and tries it was a game of skill no it
isn't you're taking your hard-earned
money and you let it [ __ ] ride and
you're either gonna come out this
weekend wearing some Elvis rings or
you're gonna be sucking dick down on
some [ __ ] Boulevard and my bookie is
not afraid to let you know that they're
a part of that world so all my listeners
if you're if you already busted your
bracket there's still a way for you to
cash in on March Madness
sorry I thought that was the end of the
sentence cash in on March Madness at my
bookie if you haven't signed up yet it's
not too late it doesn't matter if you've
been a player for years or you like a
team because their colors match your
favorite shoes lay down some money and
score big on college hoops
join me and thousands of online players
and start betting they actually gave me
some free money to bet I got a bet that
[ __ ] they gave me 500 bucks you guys
give me your picks
give me your picks and I'm gonna throw
it on there and if somebody gives me a
winner I'm giving you the money what do
you think about that at my bookie AG are
you sick and tired of getting the
runaround when you're asked for a payout
come join my bookie today I would only
recommend a service that's been good to
me and my listeners why are they putting
words in my mouth I've never [ __ ]
used it I just like the fact that
they've owned up to the fact that
they're in the gambling world that's why
evidently I'm telling you that's why I'm
reading this that says I'm telling you
to make your way to my bookie you win
they pay fast win without hassles well
there's the other side if you lose you
pay sneaky [ __ ] you're wasting
your time betting anywhere else they
even they even have live in game betting
so you can place a bet after tip-off of
Jesus - how exciting is that join now
and my bookie will match your first
deposit deposit with a 50% bonus use
promo code Burpee URR to activate this
offer visit my bookie dot AG today play
win and get paid hey then spend chat and
get late that's how it's gonna work okay
no matter what you're gonna [ __ ]
spend your money I got 500 bucks to play
with I believe once you guys pick me
some winners I'm gonna put some money on
the Kansas Jayhawks that's always been
my team I really got into college hoops
in the 90s and I just picked Kansas and
that's they've always stuck with me I
just [ __ ] I just think it's I know I
just always liked the Jayhawks all right
Trump moves to crack down on China trade
with 50 billion dollars in 11 we have
like the Christopher Walken pauses the
weird pauses drop moves to crack down on
China trade I can't do walking with 50%
tariffs on imported products he's
basically imposing this tariff evidently
because in the past he's claiming China
forced I guess the u.s. to show them how
we make [ __ ] I don't know that this is
true but you know everybody steals right
everybody steals you know like it's like
hey Pepsi where'd you get that idea
hey fourth stripe adidas what's up with
that sneaker nice design doesn't that
look familiar doesn't that look familiar
let me read this article here let me
read out loud to give you next even more
enjoyment here president Trump took his
first steps towards imposing tariffs on
50 billion in Chinese goods and limiting
China's ability to invest in the US
technology technology industry now I
have the hiccups I'm gonna plow through
the hiccups holding my breath is there a
way to scare yourself you know you scare
yourself out of the hiccups don't look
at yourself in the mirror until the next
time you get hiccups and just that small
amount of time the amount that you even
aged will scare the [ __ ] out of you all
right maybe not all right to invest the
US technology technology industry
Thursday saying the moves were a
response to Beijing's history of forcing
US companies to surrender their trade
secrets to do business in China hey you
want to [ __ ] sell that air you got a
source on you mate it's Kentucky Fried
Chicken do they have the [ __ ] secret
recipe know they have compiled Fried
Chicken how do they do it that's like
they McDowell's oh my god that's [ __ ]
hilarious let me ask you this why is why
if this is true right why the [ __ ] is
Trump blaming China why does he blame
all those [ __ ] corporation sellouts
who turned over their [ __ ] secrets
that's the corporation's fault why don't
you draw a line in the sand you [ __ ]
greedy [ __ ] hey if you want to sell
that here you guys show me how you make
it you know what go [ __ ] yourself I
remember when I used to sell [ __ ] at
theaters and if they wanted to pick them
when they started like all of a sudden
led to be like hey well you know you're
kind of using our theaters as a as a
store and then they would take try to
take 10% 20% then in one place it went
up to like 30% was like yeah I'm gonna
give me a [ __ ] 1/3 of this go [ __ ]
yourself I'm not doing it and I just
thought I stopped selling [ __ ] that's
why I don't go out there anymore
all right although I am selling a poster
on this tour I'm full of [ __ ] the
president directed US Trade
Representative Robert E lighten Heiser
Jesus Christ is he's the great-grandson
and robert e lee they changed the last
name to announce a proposed list of
products to be hit with tariff increases
within 15 days after a public comment
period the final list is designed to
target chinese products that benefit
from improper access to US technology
will be made public the end objective of
this is to get China to modify its
unfair trade practices says Everett S
eats that deputy assistant to the
president for International Economic
Affairs well why don't they tell the
[ __ ] corporation's to be you know the
[ __ ] to have a little backbone you
know get together and be like hey China
you know you want to you want to you
want to [ __ ] sell these hacky sacks
we're not gonna tell you how we make
them you want to cut it open try to
figure it out that's on you but I'm not
gonna sit and tell you I don't know who
knows as he met what that guy from Korea
yet I was so excited about that the two
[ __ ] world leaders that didn't get
along with each other yes sit down and
talk it out you know
I some food fight him over I'm come over
here show him a good time
take him on Space Mountain then left
memories little did I can't blow that up
I had a good time I met [ __ ] Donald
Duck I went on Space Mountain you know I
got a I got a [ __ ] hand job on that
[ __ ] Pirates of Penzance ride
whatever the hell is the Johnny Depp one
I don't I look forward to it I
understand it you know I've been sending
everybody that [ __ ] Michael McDonald
does Iron Maiden and you know it kills
me the amount of people that don't get
it they're like does he always sing like
that I but they don't get it's like you
have to know Iron Maiden and Michael
McDonald do you understand that's a wide
berth if you listen to and I mean the
odds for as much as people on social
media always try to say that they have I
have an eclectic eclectic taste in music
to remember that on MySpace one person
said that and then all of a sudden
everybody was using that I have very
eclectic tastes it was just this [ __ ]
way
you know this deliberate carefully
planned out way to show how [ __ ]
interesting you are and open-minded
right favorite albums back in black and
Muppets Take Manhattan I mean I'm all
over the map
okay I don't see color man and I
actually think that social media as much
as it's helped me go from the
obscurities of featuring and comedy
clubs to the heights of telling my [ __ ]
jokes and three different continents at
this point
I actually still think it's a bad thing
alright because it before social media
nobody said freebie there were way less
fake tits
speaking of which brother I can't I
can't even figure out [ __ ] Instagram
I finally I posted a picture today and
then I had to delete it because I
thought like the next screen was gonna
be the thing where you're right [ __ ] so
my wife tells me okay you got to delete
it so I delete it and then I [ __ ] oh
and then all the filters what filter am
I gonna put on this [ __ ] thing and it
actually makes you look better than you
are you should see how green and awesome
my shirt looks it looks like [ __ ] pea
soup in real life but in that one it
looked it look rich and bold patriotic
the whole [ __ ] thing is a lie but
I'll tell you what isn't a lie the
picture that I took all right with Henry
wait Stephen root and Alec Berg and Bill
Hader was supposed to be there we were
at nerdmelt on sunset and they were
promoting this incredible new show that
is debuting this Sunday March 25th I
believe at 8 o'clock Eastern Time and
name of the shows Berry's about this guy
Barry he's an eff guy he's a veteran
from the Afghani war and when he comes
back to the States
he becomes a hit man and one of his hits
is in LA he goes out to LA and it's a
long story he ends up catching the
acting bug and he's trying to transition
out of being a hitman and becoming an
actor and I can't even tell you how in
such a dark comedy it's such a funny
[ __ ] show I cannot recommend this
show enough they sent me four episodes
alright and I am jonesing for the last
for the writing the acting everything
you have to [ __ ] and watch the show you
have to watch the show you do not you
come back on Monday you have you you
[ __ ] stare at the floor you don't say
goodnight then nobody Pope of Greenwich
Village anybody what am i some kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what bank so anyways those three people
and Bill Hader was supposed to be there
and I was reading up on everybody so
because I haven't done a lot of these
interview type of things so I was
reading up on Bill Hader and they said
how one interesting fact about him he is
the voice for the planet peanut guy even
though he has a peanut allergy
so I'm sitting in the back thinking like
holy [ __ ] I'm gonna meet Henry Winkler
then my goal in this hour-long interview
is not once am I going to bring up happy
days or the fonts right
Stevan roots there I'm not bringing up
that [ __ ] red stapler I know both of
these guys have answered these questions
for million [ __ ] times I want to talk
about the present and how amazing this
goddamn show us and so I'm waiting for
everybody to come in and at the last
second right before you know I'm nervous
to do this interview I have you know
he's a big [ __ ] people and Alec Berg
worked worked on like two of my favorite
shows Curb Your Enthusiasm in Silicon
Valley both high high level comedies and
I was you know like I said a little
intimidated to meet all these people and
right before I'm gonna go out there they
show up and they say Bill Hader can't
make it he somebody put some peanut [ __ ]
like some almond milk and he's [ __ ]
Starbucks coffee and his throat was
swollen up he's fine
the man is fine so now I'm sitting there
like aw [ __ ] like I had so many
questions to ask him and I'm not talking
to Henry Winkler about happy days or
Stephen rude about the red stapler what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do and fortunately
there was such great guests they
actually sort of carried me was on
Sirius XM and it was and I learned so
much about acting and writing just
talking to them the through line with
the three of them are just how open they
were and Henry Winkler has this this
this combination that I've never seen I
think I've ever seen it
he's like the warmest nicest guy while
being unbelievably driven and just has
giant balls as far as like you go in
there you
you [ __ ] choices there is no wrong
choice I don't give a [ __ ] if this
choice acting choice is gonna make me
look stupid I'm totally committed to it
usually people like that that driven
with that much courage and all of that
like literally they they can be really
abrasive when you meet him you know that
just push it past you and he's like the
nicest [ __ ] guy ever and listening to
him talking about the like and the fact
that he went any audition for it and all
of that he wasn't sitting there going
hey I'm a [ __ ] TV legend you should be
happy to get me he went in an audition
for Steven Roots another guy same thing
talking about you go in you [ __ ]
audition you know and I was getting
advice you know from other people going
hey man you're at a certain once you're
at a certain level you don't go in and
read you know you should be getting
offers like that [ __ ] Hollywood [ __ ]
and I talked to two of them you don't
get better than those two guys and they
both told me if you want the part you go
in and read for it and I was just like
there is a [ __ ] gem right there that
I'm never gonna forget so thank you to
the two of them for telling me that
and then Alec was talking about writing
which was fascinating to me because I've
gotten to do it for the last three
seasons on efforts for family and up
until efforts for family I always wrote
for myself so I heard it I wrote it and
then I said it the way I heard it and
then all of a sudden on efforts for
family I hear it a certain way and then
we go to the table read and an actor
does it another way and there's a thing
what you got to be like he can't be like
that [ __ ] going like Oh waiting
you're supposed to clear your throat
first and do it exactly the way I hear
you have to have that thing where you
just have to be open to the way they do
it and thank God thank God I I think I
kind of figured that out certainly with
the [ __ ] actors that we got on NF is
for family it's like I'm not gonna tell
these people to do anything any other
way than the way they're doing it but
just the way Alec I hope you guys can I
don't know it works if you can go on
Sirius XM and download it the interview
it seems like everything you know even
you never miss anything anymore because
it's still available but long story
short with all this me and
is that show comes out this Sunday and
Bill hader's doing all this like you
know it's not just a straight-up comedy
like it's a really like dramatic dark
show it's I don't know it kind of has
everything that I loved and it reminded
me of one of my favorite comedies I've
mentioned this is zillion times is like
Midnight Run and I just love that movie
because like it's crazy as it got
everything was still rooted in a reality
and it had a lot of heart and all of
that type of stuff and I and this show
has that I'm telling you I'm calling it
right now that show's gonna be a big hit
and I hope you guys tune in to watch
c'mon it's [ __ ] Bill Hader Stephen
root Henry Winkler I mean you can't go
wrong you can't go wrong with that
and the rest of the cast who the actors
in the acting class that he gets into
are all incredible all right
I don't wanna oversell it but definitely
check it out when you're not betting
with my bookie on March Madness all
right well that's that Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast thank you guys for
listening have a wonderful weekend you
[ __ ] please enjoy the music and then
there's another 30 minutes of a greatest
hits Thursday from I don't know Thursday
10 years ago or whatever four years ago
four weeks ago I don't [ __ ] I don't know
how it works all right that's it I'll
talk to you on Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast and
the levels are a little too high let me
bring it down let me bring it down for
you mother fall calls hey how are you
it's March 25th a Thursday and I know
what you're thinking where the [ __ ] was
the podcast on the 22nd I was in Europe
and I brought my recorder but I forgot
the wire yeah so I [ __ ] up but you
know what we're we're gonna get through
this my 14 listeners that I'm back down
to over this this rough seven week
[ __ ] period as I try to get this
thing back up and running again I do
have a new web guy and he is since
uploaded all of the podcasts from the
beginning of time which his time began
as far as I'm concerned and my podcast
religion began in June of 2007 all right
with one of my apostles Robert Kelley
setting it up in his apartment so all
the podcasts is what we're working on
right now okay and all you guys you send
me emails and everything in trash for me
and [ __ ] and I actually appreciate the
thrashing because that means you care
alright so don't worry actually by the
time you [ __ ] listening to this thing
when you actually find it the problem is
over okay but for those of you who are
actually in the bunker and have been
able to find this [ __ ] podcast
basically we're gonna have it all up on
iTunes right now I have like three
different icons or whatever the [ __ ] you
spoke apps whatever the hell you call
them used to be that you can click on
one is the old school podcast with G
cast the other one is the one that did
on libsyn for like [ __ ] three weeks
and I hated that and now I have my new
one that I created I didn't create I
paid someone to create it see yeah see
the white man does takes credit anyways
that I paid for someone else to create
that I will now take the credit for and
banish the person who created it to some
terrible duty like they do in the police
and I'll take all credit for it but
thanks gonna she's gonna be one icon
okay this is what we're working towards
and it's taken a while because we had to
upload a couple of [ __ ] years with
the podcasts and it's all gonna be on
one icon and you're gonna click on it's
going to be the Monday morning podcast
from right now all the way back to the
beginning of time and I'm slowly
starting my own religion because those
guys they don't get in trouble and they
make a ton of money you know he [ __ ]
raped 16,000 [ __ ] kids and you know no
one's going to jail as far as I know
maybe a couple people are I don't really
you know I didn't really follow the
story you know I just heard people
talking about it last night at The
Improv and then I [ __ ] threw my two
cents in to the add to the
misinformation but anyways all this [ __ ]
is gonna be it's all gonna be under one
umbrella so it'll be nice and easy big
stupid picture of myself and we'll be
back to normal okay we had a little blip
in our relationship okay you know that
happens in all relationships you know
every once in a while for a couple of
weeks maybe you move out get your head
straight be sleep on the couch a couple
of nights that's what's going on here
nothing else alright I haven't quit
doing them you know you know the one
thing that has remained constant is I
have been continuing to do the podcast
granted two three weeks two three days
late on this one when I was over in
Scotland
Dublin and London London England and but
before I get into all of that a fan of
the podcast actually started a podcast
page well you guys can go on there and
look at some of my obscure references or
look at the words that I mispronounced
or whatever else I'm actually putting
some questions on there that I want you
guys to start answering and I'll read
them here in the podcast what's the name
of the site good [ __ ] question I
don't have it in front of me I'm winging
it this week it's mmm podcast calm I
believe let me actually do this right
now so I know I'm really gonna wing this
one this is all gonna be off the top of
my head
Christ that isn't even coming up mmm
podcast
so what the [ __ ] it is hang on I'm
typing with my middle finger enter what
do we got you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that isn't it how about thee wow you
suck you know what I'm the [ __ ] worst
is it really that bad that people can't
find this [ __ ] podcast when I can't
even have the [ __ ] decency to be
three days late and actually be prepared
that's what it is I got it I found it
and I spelt it on it it's it's this is
this is the fan page it's the mmm
podcast calm that's what you want to go
to and then you click it on and there's
a picture of me and my [ __ ] shaved
head and a big [ __ ] picture of
Bigfoot and then you scroll down and
they got all the [ __ ] that I'm that I've
been talking about on here and it's just
gonna keep getting bigger and bigger
that's what we're hoping for gives you
something else to do rather than be it
your [ __ ] job hating your life that's
what this podcast is all about it's all
about getting you through that first
[ __ ] awful death week which is why
and me of course whoring my dates out
and my stuff and trying to become a
silent millionaire what is the silent
millionaire I'll tell you what it is
it's it's a [ __ ] term that I just
invented what do you think about that
you know that's what I can do that on
this podcast oh speaking of which Robert
Kelly one of the creators of the podcast
hang on a second Bobby Kelly nothing I'm
actually doing my podcast and I was
talking about I was just talking about
how you [ __ ] helped me create the
thing over in your apartment back in the
beginning of time I'm doing it right now
as we speak but your voice is up against
my ear so you're still you know you can
talk about [ __ ] that we don't need
people to know about unless you want to
be it why didn't I [ __ ] have you on
Winnie in my podcast when you go back to
New York oh you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
with your career what's the deal are we
going on a hike today it's the gayest
thing I've ever said
caste what's the deal
one o'clock is good let me finish
running my mouth and I'll see you over
there all right
Bobby I'm doing a podcast and I'm boring
people right now I'm gonna meet you
there all right we'll go rollerblading
afterwards okay I'll see you there at
1:00 he hung up on me like he should
have um that's right I'm going on a hike
with Robert Kelly I'm bringing a fanny
pack I don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna wear
a headband maybe tie a bandana around
one of my pasty thighs like chachi on
happy days maybe I'll do that [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] it's the West Coast
nobody's paying attention there's no
reason to you know why nobody pays
attention do you realize we are at the
end of the [ __ ] day not only not only
in this country are we at the end of the
[ __ ] day okay though the world by the
time we're done talking [ __ ] in a bar
the sun's already coming up in Japan
starting the following [ __ ] day we
haven't gone to bed yet is it any wonder
everybody out here seems flaky do you
know if I wake up at 9:00 9:30 out here
it's already midday back east yes bill
we can do the math well some people
can't you know so what is the [ __ ]
point of me getting up and watching the
news or reading a newspaper because it's
gonna talk about yesterday
and it's already [ __ ] today and back
east
it's already [ __ ] Beyond halfway
through the [ __ ] day that's my excuse
so anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast and I'm doing here in a Thursday
I will be doing another one on Monday
I'll get caught up all right don't get
mad don't act like you guys don't get
behind in your lives you know stuff
starts to mount you know you can't deal
with it so you take a pill and then the
next day you know maybe I'll take two
pills and the next day you know you
[ __ ] droolin on your [ __ ] lazy boy
that's how it goes down I don't even
know what I'm gonna talk about this week
well let's talk about my trip to Europe
it was unbelievable it was an incredible
success I don't know what the [ __ ] it
was I don't as the one over they had a
great time and people showed up and I
had a great time the first place I went
to was I went to I went to London
England and I've always wanted to go
there and I have to admit I when we
landed at a Frau oh yeah I'm sweating
here roasting bacon boiling it's like a
sauna I saw my ta fro yay did they-did
mate I saw him at a fro sorry every time
I say Heathrow I have to say hey fro and
then I just start doing lines from sexy
piece cuz I love that [ __ ] movie you
know I love that movie because they it's
it's the best [ __ ] chick flick ever
I've said this before and I'll [ __ ]
say it again okay next time your girl's
like that's really like a romantic movie
I'd like to see something you know you
just been watching too many action
movies it's like I don't like him but is
my son different tonight can I pick it
out okay can I pick it up like you
didn't [ __ ] pick out every other one
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what let me
step up to the plate sweetheart alright
once you unbutton another button on your
[ __ ] shirt give me a little
excitement on the way the [ __ ] video
store and I'll pick out the romantic
movie and you come out with sexy beast
oh I got a sexy death scandalous this
isn't like a nine and a half weeks no
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] love story why are
you always that to call me that
because you are a [ __ ] no sorry um
that's a [ __ ] great story it's about
a guy who just he loves this woman and
he has his own [ __ ] place in the
middle of nowhere and everything's going
[ __ ] great basically if you ever
watch a gangster movie you know one of
the reoccurring themes to the point that
now it's become cliched is there's
always the guy who's just gonna do one
more job and then he's getting out you
know same thing in the Vietnam movies I
got one more tour dude I'm sure I
shouldn't be on
point son right and you know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen to him right and I
even believe the Wayans brothers and one
of them movies make fun of those those
those [ __ ] around the way movies with
is the the black guy who kid who's gonna
[ __ ] go to college you know and he
stayed strong he didn't get in the game
and then he walks up and he's [ __ ]
eating some ice cream and he gets shot
in an alley or some [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] happens you know what I
mean so anyways this movie actually is
about a couple of guys who succeeded
they did their last job they got their
money and they got out of the [ __ ]
game and they're living in Spain they're
married to a couple of hot [ __ ]
broads and they don't have any kids so
it's great and you know what you do when
you don't have any [ __ ] kids and
you're married to a hot broad you still
[ __ ] and you barbecue and you lay next
to your pool gunner yeah I'm sweating
here roast and baked and boiling just
[ __ ] chilling out having a great
[ __ ] time that's where the movie
begins and then trouble ensues and go
[ __ ] rent it I love that goddamn
movie every time I see it it gets better
so anyways we landed at a throw watching
telly
is this Stan sorry this is getting
obnoxious like the rest of it isn't so
we landed at Heathrow and we got in a
cab you know and I started driving down
the [ __ ] other side of the road and
we're driving through it I'm looking at
England and you know London and you know
what I'm not liking it I'm like look at
this [ __ ] shitty town I just it just
didn't appeal to me and I think the real
thing was I was jet-lagged because I
ended up loving it but I was [ __ ]
really jet-lagged
and my girlfriend's gonna kill me if I
tell this story this is basically this
base what happened I got a first-class
ticket over there right but it was
basically from New Jersey to London a
free
a fro Airport and this is what has
happened my entire career every time I
get a first-class [ __ ] ticket which
is rare I get a first-class [ __ ]
thing let me answer to answer that
question before you get like Bill you at
the point will you fly first-class you
ever way you go not even [ __ ] close
okay most of those people that you see
in first-class they got bumped up
because they fly so much because I'm
gonna tell you a [ __ ] first-class
ticket is 1200 to 1500 bucks a month all
right so if I buy two of those a month
that's like an extra it's [ __ ] three
grand on my credit card as opposed to
like [ __ ] 600 bucks 700 or whatever
but to coach tickets and you know that
adds up all right times 12 months that's
36 [ __ ] grand just so you can get on
the plane first and [ __ ] stretch your
legs out right so basically the only
time I fly first-class is is if they
hook me up other than that I'll [ __ ]
sit in the back with my knees against my
chest I don't give a [ __ ] I got the
whole thing worked out this is how I do
it all right this is how I do it
first thing I do when I sit down is I
take my wallet out of my back pocket
because I'm one of these guys that has
like nine years of business cards bank
receipts cash sheesh all this [ __ ] in my
wallet and right off the bat
yeah this is so [ __ ] up it's it's
[ __ ] on one ass cheek
so it's [ __ ] messes up you like my
back my alignment and if I sit it on sit
on it too hard it's like sitting on a
[ __ ] stone and it makes me bum a
little sensitive so I take that [ __ ]
out I stick it in my front pocket and
then I just make sure every couple hours
I get up I always get an aisle seat
which sucks because people are gonna
crawl over you but uh you know I don't
like being that guy when I gotta take a
leak in the person next to me has that
lapped
about and then they do that well [ __ ]
get a first-class ticket you douche Oh
get an aisle seat
who's your [ __ ] travel agent where
you're sitting in the middle so anyways
I get up every couple hours and I do a
little mini yoga thing down the back of
the plane you know I just do it I got
this little hole stretching routine that
I do because I fly so [ __ ] much and
that's how much your first-class ticket
is that I would rather sit in the back
with my wallet in my front pocket doing
yoga back near the [ __ ]
that's how expensive first classes so
anyway so I get this first-class ticket
from Joisey Newark New Jersey to to
London in a fro doughnut a fro London
England and this is what has always
happened whenever I've gotten a first
class at least half the [ __ ] time
when I'm gone when I'm flying first
class it means I'm going someplace
that's awesome or the gig is gonna be
awesome and what always ends up
happening is somebody else wants to
[ __ ] go and then they always go dude
you're giving your first-class [ __ ] that
you lose your anyway like you know maybe
you could you know just take a buy on
get to [ __ ] coach tickets so
basically half the times I've gotten a
first-class ticket I haven't gotten to
fly first-class I'm sitting back there
with with a manager or a [ __ ] agent
or who knows what a buddy who wants to
come along to go check out the gig
because it's gonna be awesome so I never
get to fly so long story [ __ ] short
is you know I spent five months on the
road getting ready for to tape let it go
which by the way looks [ __ ] awesome I
was just looking that's my new special
coming out so anyways I you know I never
get to fly first-class so I get I just
totally lost my train of thought see
look at one week off of Lumosity calm
and my brains [ __ ] up yeah so this is
the deal so I get a first-class ticket
to go to [ __ ] from New Jersey to
London right a
and my girl goes I wanna go can I go oh
you're going someplace fun she only
wants to go to the fun places she
doesn't come to like [ __ ] you know
Pittsburgh when I need her
[ __ ] Madison Wisconsin she doesn't
want to go on those I'm going to Matt
Miami then all of a sudden say oh my god
I love Miami what do you need from me I
need you to love Cincinnati that's what
the [ __ ] I need from you why don't you
come on those trips that's when I
[ __ ] need you so anyway she's going
to Europe right there's nothing you know
there's no [ __ ] way of course I'm
gonna take her so this is deal I spent
five months on the [ __ ] road with my
knees to my chest my wallet my front
[ __ ] pocket going in the back doing
[ __ ] yoga cuz I had to make sure I
had a great special of course they ended
up catching a cold and I did my special
with dayquil that's a whole nother story
so basically you know 41 year old guy my
body's [ __ ] junk this is my first
time going to the UK and then over to
Dublin and then back to [ __ ] Scotland
which I believe you know I'm a little
confused exactly what is Great Britain
and what is the United Kingdom it's
really [ __ ] confusing they got so
many goddamn aliases over there alright
as far as I understand Great Britain is
England Wales and Scotland and maybe
even the top of Ireland with the [ __ ]
was all those goddamn [ __ ] fight and
Belfast okay is is that is that the
United is the United Kingdom that is
Great Britain just England and [ __ ]
Wales is that Great Britain or is Great
Britain in England Wales and [ __ ]
Scotland
why don't I look at it I didn't look it
up [ __ ] you this is my question for the
week what what's the difference between
the United Kingdom and and and Great
Britain because before I went over there
I wanted to learn some of the countries
over there so I didn't come off as a
dumbass American then I found out there
was 50 countries and I
like all right [ __ ] it I'll just learn
it over to like Greece Romania Ukraine
eeeh Lithuania all the Aeneas Russia
half of Georgia half a turkey and then
once you get the cast and go [ __ ]
yourself over the hell you said I was
under the impression that England was a
country and then when I was looking up
the names of country it didn't say that
it said Great Britain
so Great Britain is the country what
does that include and what is the United
Kingdom the rest of Ireland isn't part
of it is it or are you I don't know you
little ass [ __ ] pieces of land over
there maybe you guys got a band together
you know like a bunch of [ __ ] Cubans
coming over here in a refrigerator door
floating over to [ __ ] the keys you
know I don't know so anyways so this is
the deal so I get a first-class ticket
from Jersey to a free London and my girl
wants to go so once again I'm in that
situation I'm in that situation and it's
like you know what I gotta put my foot
down I finally did I said look this is
much fun as we're gonna have over there
and everything this is a business trip I
have to go over there I have to be
[ __ ] relaxed I'm already gonna be
jet-lagged and I have to hit three home
runs in a [ __ ] row I got a kill in
London I got a kill in Dublin and I got
a kill in Glasgow all right so as much
as you want to run around and go buy
some trinkets and [ __ ] I have to be
rested up for this stuff so this is the
deal I will fly coach with you to Jersey
and then I'm going up first-class to
England and I put her in the back left
her in the back and you know there was
some rough waters trying to convince her
of that and I was like look this is the
deal I'm gonna go over there I'm gonna
[ __ ] hit and then what if I [ __ ]
blow up over there flies both over there
first [ __ ] class so because my girls
[ __ ] the [ __ ] she says fine so I'm
like that's it man you see that [ __ ]
macdaddy [ __ ] pimp got what the [ __ ]
I wanted and
this is what's funny two days before we
go to leave I get hit with this [ __ ]
wave of guilt oh wait a second by the
way I looked into getting her first
class [ __ ] taking you what these
[ __ ] [ __ ] want they wanted like
[ __ ] five grand just from Jersey it's
[ __ ] ridiculous it's so [ __ ] it's
so [ __ ] ridiculous why is it 1500 to
fly 2800 miles but all of a sudden 3,000
miles below over 3,300 miles because I'm
going to a different country they all of
a sudden your foot you make it like
three and a half times the [ __ ] price
so I can't do that I go over there I'm
gonna lose a couple of grand so I just
you know [ __ ] she complained she
complained a little bit and I go are you
complaining about a free [ __ ] ticket
to Europe is that what you're doing
right now so anyways I ended up feeling
[ __ ] guilty and whatever so I got her
some DVDs so anyways you finally landed
in a throw and I we get off the plane
and I wait for her and [ __ ] and I notice
that she's you know kind of give me the
cold shoulder or whatever I'm like
what's the problem
and I I came about how when cuz I was so
[ __ ] tired she was pissed cuz I
didn't go back to see her during the
flight you know come back there I mean
what were we gonna talk about I was
gonna come back to him be like yeah he's
just flying coach still suck
alright I was just checking you know cuz
it kind of seemed like it sucked from LA
to New Jersey but I was wondering maybe
it got better I'm actually in defense
myself I tried to go back there but they
had a velvet rope okay and I'm not
saying that they had a bunch of Janet
Jackson CDs there they actually had a
velvet rope there and I was not allowed
to go past there and I said fine alright
so I got out of that one so whatever
whatever alright so we landed a throw
and we get in the [ __ ] car we drive
over to the hotel and I'm just looking
at it going this looks a little
very gray very overcast and it was
disappearing into a lot of gray
buildings and I'm like what the [ __ ] I
don't like this and then I'm you know
and I took a [ __ ] nap and then I woke
up and then we did what New Yorkers
[ __ ] do all right
we don't take tours I do consider myself
a [ __ ] New Yorker but not now I don't
not affiliated with any of their sports
teams but I lived there for [ __ ] 12
years and I loved it and this is what
New Yorkers do when we go to a [ __ ]
new city public transportation baby show
me where your [ __ ] subway is and I'll
do it that way we hit a couple you know
Big Ben Parliament bang zoom then we
just walked the [ __ ] around and we find
the cool places to go to all right we
don't go to the dumb [ __ ] like one of my
buddies when you go to Dublin go to
Temple Bar yeah that's the [ __ ] place
to go yeah so I'm gonna have a drink
with some guy from Cleveland you [ __ ]
[ __ ] go where all the tourists go I've
never [ __ ] understood why you would
go on vacation to then hang out with a
bunch of other douchebags who aren't
from where the [ __ ] you're going so what
what experience do you gain there what
somebody from Rhode Island is like in
London it's the dumbest [ __ ] ever okay
you want to see a couple of things like
when I got admit when I saw Big Bend it
was it was [ __ ] awesome I've seen
pictures of that and you know I'm a I
loved watching Wimbledon Wimbledon I for
years I've been saying Wimbledon yeah
yet another word that I've been
mispronouncing tio and Wimble done but
it's Wimble done deal and Wimbledon
they just say too [ __ ] fast for my
dumb ears to projects he's not my dumb
ears my brains too dumb to process the
signals from my ears I think my ears are
okay but anyways so there that's what we
did so I saw a Big Ben and it was just
[ __ ] iconic who's the [ __ ] all those
years watching Wimbledon breakfast at
Wimbledon and then they they always show
Big Ben and it was incredible and got a
what else - [ __ ] that I do oh I know I
wanted to that
torta to the [ __ ] Abbey Road Studios
fell through it's a long [ __ ] story
they couldn't do it Wednesday and by
when they wanted to do it Thursday I was
doing radio and it just didn't [ __ ]
work out so I'll have to do that next
time but uh so I was like alright that
didn't work out I have to go see Royal
Royal Albert Hall now for those of you
who are Led Zeppelin fans you know the
importance of that building and if you
got their their last DVD that came out
it has this [ __ ] unbelievable concert
that they gave at Royal Albert Hall and
I always wanted to go there it's really
difficult to say Royal Albert Hall and
it was something that was built I
believe by this Queen Victoria did I
just say this Queen Victoria it's this
[ __ ] broad Queen Victoria she was
into this guy Prince [ __ ] Albert and I
guess they were unbelievably in love
with each other and the way that they
expressed love was they they bought
pieces of art with the money from the
poor that's what they did
they were so in love that rather than
taking all the [ __ ] disgusting amount
of taxes from the poor people and using
it to feed them they said no let's spend
it lavishly on ourselves in this
unbelievable art collection that we and
we alone could sit here and stare at
it's just [ __ ] I don't know that
whole royalty thing is hilarious to me
so yeah that's what they did and I don't
know and then Prince Albert he caught
the clap which evidently was fatal back
in the day they cheated on her but she
still loved him and something like that
I didn't really read the story you can
look it up I don't what the [ __ ] he got
he got like what do what he did die of
in the 1800s the mumps he got
tuberculosis he got something okay he
was [ __ ] Victoria out and the Great
Lawn and some mosquito bit him and next
thing you know he had typhoid fever I
don't he died suddenly
so she was overcome with grief and a lot
of people say she never got over it and
what she did was she built this big [ __ ]
and statue of this guy that actually is
not gold-plated but gold leaf Affleck I
don't know what it's as actual [ __ ]
gold in it
and it's got a big opulent roof to it so
the pigeons can't [ __ ] on the guy and
you know what yet again yet again to
express her love for another human being
why would you help other human beings
let's spend more of the poor people's
money on this this it's pretty
impressive not gonna lie to you
so anyways went over we saw that [ __ ]
and they were actually giving a tour of
Royal Albert Hall so I wanted to go and
it was an hour delay and my girl hates
tourists
she's a [ __ ] New Yorker she's like oh
my god I can [ __ ] finger it out myself
what it's a [ __ ] building so Mike can
we just just for me can we just [ __ ]
do this so she's like fine so long story
short may we end up going on the bloody
tour and it just so happens that the
London Philharmonic is practicing in
there I don't know for a gig later on
that night or the next day I have no
idea what so the guy brings us in there
and we walk in two boxes down from where
the Queen's box is okay I'm waiting for
the beavis and butt-head laugh that he
said Queens box the box where the Queen
sits in we are just basically
unbelievable seats and we come walking
in and as we sit down and take in
basically the most beautiful theatre
I've ever seen in my life the beauty of
the theatre right as we sit down the
orchestra begins playing as if they were
waiting for us and it was so
unbelievably beautiful and so
overwhelming that my girlfriend actually
started to cry so and I started laughing
at my girlfriend crying because I was
actually afraid that I was going to get
emotional that's how [ __ ]
unbelievable it was it was incredible it
was in that moment I was like [ __ ] this
I have to see a concert here it was in
credit and everybody was basically on
our tour with
sitting there with like I like that I
don't have the ability to describe the
sound it was the most unbelievable sound
I've ever heard in my life and it
actually made me less cynical
that's how beautiful was I actually felt
I actually what the [ __ ] was it I got
how do I put this it was like I you know
I'm real cynical when I think of people
I think that pieces of [ __ ] they [ __ ]
lie they're greedy they're weak
cowardice and all that [ __ ] thing and
then you just see this group of people
in this building like everything was
perfect the construction of it the the
way they decorated it and the whoever
wrote the music and then all the gifted
people playing it was it was it was
[ __ ] unbelieving there it was like
something that I will never forget and
then ten seconds later the tour guys
like alright we got to go we got to go
and no one wanted to go and then he's
like out in the hall going and then this
wall here was constructed by Henry the
[ __ ] eighth Andrew thinks nobody
gives a [ __ ] we want to go back in there
listen to the band
it was unreal so what would happen was
we just kept going to these room two
rooms the green room where the Queen
hangs out and has her royal bush trimmed
or whatever the [ __ ] they do and then we
would we would be in a different part of
the theatre and we would dip in we would
what we would listen to them play again
and this is the thing you were not
allowed to take video in the place but
fortunately I'm an ignorant American and
I didn't give a [ __ ] and I brought a
little those little flip cameras in
there and I actually I got some video
footage in there that I will be putting
up on my website I'm just gonna try to
edit it all together actually follow
through on this and make a nice video of
my trip to Europe but I got to tell you
guys something right [ __ ] now okay
[ __ ] going to Sea World [ __ ] the San
Diego Zoo [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
going to Chicago and going to the top of
the Sears Tower and going to Wrigley
Field that shit's all gonna be there you
[ __ ]
here alright no biggie
you can drive to all of those things let
me tell you something save your [ __ ]
money who gives a [ __ ] it's not worth
anything anyways
get yourself a ticket at some point go
look up Royal Albert Hall if you're into
classical music they have they call them
prom shows I don't know what that was
short for but they have like this this
like month or two six-week period where
they just have all these orchestras come
in if you're into classical music I saw
another concert in October Jeff Beck is
playing there you know that guy's you
know it's weird he's getting up there in
years and he's at the primers career
basically what I'm saying if you're a
music lover at some point in your life
if you're if you're everything even into
just [ __ ] architecture you have to go
see a show there okay I'm telling you it
was [ __ ] unbelievable alright and
that's it that's it for that [ __ ]
alright unbelievable so I'm gonna try to
get back there booked a gig and I have
to see I have to see and I would [ __ ]
see anybody there Wow I did okay let's
let's be [ __ ] honest I got to admit
jay-z and Beyonce were there I wouldn't
want to see jay-z at Royal Albert Hall
I just wouldn't you know I was actually
picturing Led Zeppelin there and like
the place was so beautiful it almost
seemed like [ __ ] offensive you know
for them to be singing the lemon song
talking about singing poetically about
getting your dick sucked in someplace
that beautiful now I'm not [ __ ] on
jay-z or anything I think that guy's a
[ __ ] genius but you know what I mean
like I don't think that I like if I ever
got a gig there I'd want to do it just
to Zeppelin's bend this anatra JZ and
all these guys these unbelievable
artists but for me to go up there the
way I curse it just wouldn't be right
alright you know this is why you travel
the world is you get you two reasons why
you travel okay one is to see all the
unbelievable things that are out there
and realize how much more there is than
what you thought there was and then
two on the other side is to realize you
know as you start to get you know
homesick why you love where you live
because that definitely happened because
I gotta admit I [ __ ] went hardcore
with the food over there I kept getting
the traditional English breakfast the
traditional Irish Breakfast I got a
traditional Scottish breakfast and I'm
telling you dude it's [ __ ] like how
those people are still walking around
past the age of 40 it's [ __ ] unreal
traditional English breakfast was eggs
sausage of bangers as they call them
bacon and that bacon is more like
Canadian bacon where it looks like you
took the zest of a pig with a big grater
and just took a [ __ ] shingle of pig
and threw it and threw it into a frying
pan so you got the [ __ ] sausage the
shingle of pig and then you had love
pork and beans and then I don't know
something else I gotta tell you all that
[ __ ] pork basically two helpings of
pork three helpings of [ __ ] pork they
have the sausage sausage Canadian bacon
style to the 10th power in pork and
beans with eggs and then toast you know
then you have a cup of tea and I gotta
admit to it I [ __ ] loved it I
absolutely loved it but like now a week
later physically I'm feeling the [ __ ]
pay every morning I got up and I got
that breakfast and what else did I do I
went to I went to oh the crosswalk there
I got the picture the Abbey Road thing
the picture comes out like [ __ ] because
you got to be standing in the middle of
the [ __ ] Road and I took a video of
it you got to see it it's one of the
greatest tourist not even to do it just
to observe it because basically if
you're not familiar with the Beatles you
know it's a really a shame you should
listen to their music okay that's like
the biggest understatement of all
[ __ ] time but basically you know
Abbey Road is basically
the four Beatles walking across the
crosswalk so now everybody when they go
there was a Beatles fan it has to have
four people and take that [ __ ]
picture and the reality is they've
actually moved the crosswalk like 20
feet down the [ __ ] Street see now
walking where they walked but anyways
the greatest [ __ ] thing is people
stop in the [ __ ] crosswalk because
they want to get the goddamn picture
which I think actually [ __ ] up the
picture because I think they took the
picture where they were all walking but
long story short all the poor bastards
who live over there have to live in that
part of town they have to deal with that
every [ __ ] day it's the most annoying
touristy thing I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life and you got all these
people all excited oh my god it's Abbey
road right let's get this I want to be
John Lennon and I'll oh let me be Paul
running around in these and then you
just listen to these English people beep
in the hoenn if for [ __ ] sakes you
[ __ ] cards beat the hobbits it was
awesome the whole thing was awesome so
we're actually getting this almost like
38 minutes in and I have to [ __ ] meet
Bobby to go on a hike so I gotta wrap
this [ __ ] up here quickly
so anyways did all that type of [ __ ] saw
Big Ben went out had some drinks had a
great [ __ ] time and then I did my
show and the show at the Leicester
theatre went went incredible I just had
an awesome time man and I want to thank
really from the bottom my heart
everybody who came out in England and
London Dublin and in Glasgow was [ __ ]
awesome so so basically yeah we did that
and then the next day we we flew over to
Dublin and the Irish people were just
[ __ ] hilarious
my show at the sugar club went
unbelievable and afterwards I was
hanging out with the crowd I had a
couple of drinks with people and this
[ __ ] guy's like this Irish guy comes
up to me he goes hi raffia I don't even
let me but you have anybody a drink ha
yeah right and he [ __ ] buys me a
goddamn drink and then he won't [ __ ]
leave he says sweaty drunk dude with
this he looks like he plays in a grunge
band you know what the [ __ ] hat on
and he just won't [ __ ] leave and he's
drunk and he keeps coming up and he
keeps trying to touch my [ __ ] hair
which I had mousse
up what I have left on top right so
finally he ends up [ __ ] he comes out
of nowhere with this sweaty drunk hair
and it [ __ ] like pets the top of my
head another man pet the top of my head
it's my girl goes do what the [ __ ]
you're doing and she goes he goes I'm
sorry I touched his weave now let me
tell you something I am a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but when somebody gets me with a
good one
the only reason why I didn't burst out
laughing and [ __ ] high-five him for
how [ __ ] funny that was was because
he's one of these psychos that if you
give him any sort of I wasn't even
giving him any of any attention he
wouldn't [ __ ] leave so actually if I
actually did and then I was laughing
later like me and my girl both [ __ ]
laughing that he said was a weave and
it's like maybe because I shaved my head
and when I grew it back I had a lot more
hair than people thought I did that he
thought I got hair plugs or something
but ah man it was [ __ ] hilarious so
anyways that was Dublin that we thought
was only in Dublin for like two seconds
we got this hilarious cab driver and he
was driving us to the airport
oh and by the way all these Scottish
guys were over there because they had
this huge rugby match and I totally got
into the rugby over there
they got this league the the Six Nations
League that I think is Scotland Wales
England
Ireland France and Italy there's only
six teams so reminded me of hockey like
the [ __ ] original six there's not
that many players so you can get to know
the teams so long story short if Ireland
won the game the day we were leaving if
Ireland win the game then they were the
champions of the league and if Scotland
lost they would be the worst team in the
league thus winning the wooden spoon
wooden spoon they actually give you a
[ __ ] award it's like like you don't
know that you were the worst just in
case you forget another dog be they give
you something called the wooden spoon
you know just so people can [ __ ] rub
that I think that's brilliant [ __ ]
brilliant
I think it's it's hilarious because
that's
a great way to give like a team [ __ ] I
take the Pittsburgh Pirates how many
[ __ ] wooden spoons would they well
they would be like the New York Yankees
of wooden spoons it's just a whole
nother level to give somebody [ __ ] so
basically when we were over there all
these squats came over to watch the game
and all the Irish people were talking
[ __ ] I was just [ __ ] great talking
about their their their kilts you know
and so I got so amped up by watching
these guys give each other's [ __ ] and I
wasn't getting any American sports that
I when I landed and Scouten and the next
day I actually watched the game and it
was a [ __ ] great game and Scotland
won they actually won and avoided
getting the wooden spoon and Ireland
actually lost the championship because
of that and I believe France won whether
it's just something wrong about French
people winning a rugby contest you know
championship considering the stereotype
of them and considering I'd never been
there wait a minute this guy wasn't
Andre the Giant French the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I'm such an idiot all right
scratch all that whatever so I got into
it and then my last night there I I went
to the Lyons Theatre in Glasgow Scotland
and you know I was so tempted to go out
there but I didn't want to [ __ ] my show
up by pissing everybody off but I really
wanted to go up and open with rather be
like hey you guys doing I really
appreciate you coming out because you
don't know who the hell I am I really
felt like coming out there and just
going how you doing your [ __ ] skirt
wearing [ __ ] just open it just to see
what they do and I realize halfway
through the show that they probably
would have laughed but I got great video
of all of them because I got the whole
crowd saying you're listening to the
Monday morning podcast you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you can't understand what they're
saying cuz there's too many of them I
had my heart in the right place maybe
I'll put it up with some actual what are
they subtitles underneath it you're
watching that yeah you're listening to
the Monday morning podcast your [ __ ]
coats they really leaned into it too
I'll put the video it's all gonna be
part of the video but I sincerely want
to thank everybody who came out to see
my shows I was unbelievably flattered by
the the reception I got when I was over
there like people were actually clapping
like they knew who I was and it was
incredible and that was another thing
that I learned when I was over there was
the like the different levels of Fame
like over here I have a like I say I
have notoriety that's where I'm at you
know second degree notoriety like every
once awhile someone's like hey you're
that comedian guy right yeah thank you
funny I saw you yeah used to be on there
you're on that show right weren't you on
that show yeah yeah I was on this show
but just to go over there and see I said
like John Mayer had a sold-out show at
Wembley Stadium and added a second show
and I was like wow that [ __ ] dude is
famous okay and you know when we get
into the entertainment game and as a
performer and you start you know trying
to sell tickets you know the first time
you sell out a [ __ ] comedy club you
can't believe it and just to see someone
to be able to move that amount of
tickets on the other side of the [ __ ]
world it's it's unreal
for those of you unfamiliar with Wembley
Stadium this is how big it is
evel knievel did a stunt there he
[ __ ] jumped over like like 30 buses
London double deckers granted he didn't
[ __ ] make it but just picture how
fast you'd have to get a motorcycle
going today forget about a motorcycle 40
[ __ ] years ago or 35 years ago that
probably weighed two tonnes and he bet
he cleared the buses I think he landed
on the last one that's ahead let's some
footage right there that you might want
to check all UX game people cuz he's the
[ __ ] father all of that [ __ ]
so anyways John Mayer sold that [ __ ]
place out and he's he's got another one
coming up added a show there so I was
really humbled going over there and and
I'm looking forward to coming back again
went to a concert at Royal Albert Hall
going to it'll be game in either
Scotland or [ __ ] Ireland and just
coming through all those again I
definitely wanna build up a following
over there because I had a great time
after actually actually after my my gig
in the Lyons theatre I went over to this
this comedy club and dude it was [ __ ]
hilarious we walked in there and we were
listening to the host of the show and
the guy is he's speaking English and we
cannot understand 80% of what he's
saying so we are laughing along with the
crowd not at the jokes just [ __ ] hide
rejected a [ __ ] hundred it's like what
you guys remember that when went in
snatch when Brad Pitt played that Irish
character you couldn't understand this
was the Scot and Scotland version of
that and I met this comedian Kevin
Bridges who's I guess huge over there
right not even guess he is huge over
there afterwards we having a couple of
pints and I started talking about the
word [ __ ] and I was too drunk I wish I
filmed it listening to these guys talk
about the word [ __ ] the way they say it
now would have been so perfect on this
podcast at some point I have to I have
to interview one of those two guys on
this podcast but I was sitting there
going yeah yeah we're like blown away
how you guys can just say [ __ ] and it's
not offensive and they're like yeah I
everybody says that when they come over
here have a bob up on all this [ __ ]
right so I was talking to him Mike yeah
you actually use it as like like a
compliment you say stuff like I you know
he's a good [ __ ] and the other guy goes
he goes oh he's a great [ __ ]
top [ __ ] so there you go there's a new
expression for you he's a top [ __ ] I
think that's the greatest things I've
ever heard so I'm saying to these guys
[ __ ] why don't I film you would've loved
this [ __ ] if you're a stand-up geek he
didn't want you and you just want to see
like we would trade notes like I was
saying so I go so what is basically the
c-word what is the word you can't say
over in in Scotland and he
[ __ ] is what he said [ __ ] and he
tried he was explaining it to me but but
granted we were both [ __ ] shit-faced
and I could barely understand what this
dude was saying when we were balls sober
right but he was I guess it means I
couldn't figure it meant some form of
like [ __ ] slash vegetable and like I
don't know like that they just don't you
just you don't talk about that stuff
over there if you do
I guess it's literally needle going off
the [ __ ] record player but so I
thought that that was really I thought
that that was interesting what else oh
here's something you guys better brace
yourselves for as far as pop culture
thing that I saw over there on there
American Idol over there there's a
there's these these twins and they got
these high-top fades like that dude from
kiddin play I think it was play the
light-skinned dude right with the
[ __ ] high-top for that [ __ ] beyond
that the Eraserhead fade right two white
kids they both have that do their twins
named John and Edward and they go by the
name Jedward I swear to God and they're
really into Vanilla Ice they think
Vanilla Ice is awesome and the reporter
was going you know people kind of
ridiculed him and they're like oh when
he freestyles he's lethal so I didn't
even have to hear what the [ __ ] they
sing I just know that some [ __ ] is so
bad it's [ __ ] awesome so I'm just
just telling you to get prepared for
that because I think that that could go
global that's it's like the perfect
storm of [ __ ] awful so do you
remember you heard it here first in the
States watch out for Jedward look them
up if you have to
alright well 50 minutes into this thing
I got a [ __ ] rap this [ __ ] thing
up what did I want to talk about I have
any [ __ ] any other stories whatever
this is just the English podcast I'll
give you one [ __ ] overrated
underrated thing that's really annoying
the [ __ ] out of me
is this whole thing that when you're
going to get a [ __ ] burrito
all right or a taco and they ask you
what toppings you want and you get
whatever toppings you want and all of a
sudden if you want to get guacamole this
whole [ __ ] that guacamoles extra oh
that's fifty cents extra that's a dollar
extra like avocados are [ __ ] rare
maybe on the East Coast but I gotta
admit I got a - friends of mine who
owned houses out here
they got [ __ ] avocado trees in their
goddamn yards they just it's one of
those things where just like diamonds I
always you always hear that rumor that
you know diamonds aren't really rare
they just say they are and they just
control how many go out that's what
they're trying to do with [ __ ]
guacamole I put up with it it was one
kind of [ __ ] food I didn't give a
[ __ ] I paid extra for the guacamole I
didn't give a [ __ ] you know what I
did
I came by became part of the mechanism
that created that new corporate [ __ ]
[ __ ] way of making extra money and I'll
tell you why because you know what I got
a breakfast sandwich the other day and
bacon was extra you know like all of a
sudden that's this big [ __ ] commodity
so you can add that to your [ __ ] list
of overpriced overpriced [ __ ]
[ __ ] disposable razors locked up
behind the [ __ ] counter like they're
jewels
orange juice guacamole and [ __ ] now
bacon so this is what we got to do
everybody the fourteen [ __ ] people if
they say it's extra be like you know
what that I don't want it why don't you
sit on your [ __ ] bacon let's smell it
going bad that's it I'm not playing
[ __ ] ball the only time I'm [ __ ]
getting guacamole is going on at home
and I'll make it myself or if these
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't charge me any extra
money but you know what they'll do right
you know what that though they're all
right it's not extra anymore but the
[ __ ] burritos 50% more and they'll
blame 9/11 because of 9/11 they always
win they always win there's the last
thing I want to tell you this is one
thing I loved about Scotland you know
they say [ __ ] over there
they say [ __ ] these [ __ ] hires
doing drugs
the floor was the flower I'm [ __ ] up
the accent well these [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing drugs
hers [ __ ] hot jelly they said I had
[ __ ] loved it I loved every [ __ ]
second of it
that's it that's the end of the podcast
I got some [ __ ] I gotta [ __ ] do I
apologize that this thing was so late
but I'm telling you you know good things
come to those who [ __ ] wait I think
this was a great podcast I'm gonna Pat
myself on the back listen to this that
was me
it's really [ __ ] the back of my neck
my spine area in the [ __ ] hurt all
right you guys have a great week god
bless and don't worry it's a little
rough time here it's sort of a podcast
recession we're riding our way through
it all right I'll talk to your [ __ ]
[ __ ] later
[Music]
[Applause]